welcome back to the Julian podcast start
it off with a handshake friends friends
we are this episode's brought to you by
me and these guys check out there feel
free collection right now when you go to
me undies dot-com / channel you get 15%
off your first pair of free shipping in
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
it's an awesome new collection always
made with the micro modal supersoft
fabric check it out also guys
Squarespace if you're building a website
do a square space because Keanu Reeves
does it the end go to Squarespace comm
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com slash
angelina save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or domain or click
the link down below it is a great
website hosting service if you're
looking to build one for your personal
hobby or even professional needs check
them out thank you sponsors I'm wearing
me on these Pizza ones
what is Pizza no underwear well pizza on
it what am I wearing I'm wearing the
well it's like colorful camo you don't
need to show us oh yeah in the free show
oh come on entice I'm happy that it's
technically fall the Solstice has
happened and now I can wear hoodies and
hats and beat my natural environment
oh it happened yesterday yes so it's not
anymore
you forgot the solstice how dare you or
the equinox which one is it wow you
don't even know if it's Equinox the
winter solstice summer solstice spring
equal remains that calendar good [ __ ]
dude it's like overcast today and it
wasn't the day before so like you know
good job you really knew as you do it to
really know what you were doing told
back whenever you made our calendar when
you were looking at the Stars and making
some type of calendar good for you good
job you oh we had too much coffee
already I feel like it's the vitamins is
that what it is yeah is that what
taking like a multivitamin that has be
an iron and sometimes I honestly forget
to take this and it makes the difference
in how you feel about vitamins e prisons
Inc no vitamins e it is it's in the new
complex we're taking I'm pretty good
about taking like vitamin B but I'm sure
I'm missing some nutrients in there
during my day and it's helpful to take a
multivitamin what if we podcast it not
looking at each other I'm down the whole
entire podcast you can look it okay no
eye contact but I can look at you up
there
I can only see me up there I can't see
you do you like well they do it yeah
hold on one second what what do you have
in there no you pulled out a whole mini
Hydra flash last I need it seemed like
through my glasses oh yeah it's great
looks good babe
I'm excited that it's fall are you I am
excited as well I've had enough of the
hot being honestly the heat version of
Snowden everyday that's what we've been
I mean for like literally over a month
now we haven't been able unless we're up
at the crack of dawn which is very few
and far between we can't really walk the
dog so it's too damn hot can't even walk
our people selves it's too hot
yeah or in the evening we can walk in
the evening too but it's like it's just
it's gonna be nice to have some weather
I've been seeing clouds the last couple
of days you know just the clouds have
been and we're going to this weekend
we're going to twitchcon this weekend
are you excited yeah I'm excited is our
third twitchcon is our third well second
officially the first one we just kind of
like by but you counts no you're right
we go on a twitchcon I'm very excited
this has become my new favorite event of
the year
because we get to see all our friends
that we spend so much time on video
games with it's gonna be a good time
we're gonna do it to him and we're
taking bunny she's going to a little
place where a lady has a bunch of
greyhounds the ghost day yeah yeah and
I'm excited for that we found this woman
through gray save she watches primarily
greyhounds but other dogs as well and
spoke with her a couple months back when
we were making arrangements for
twitchcon and she you know she sounded
great like you know our usual spot is
bringing her to her foster dad's house
cuz he'll he'll always watch her but
he's out of town this weekend so she's
gonna have a new spot but she's doing so
well
she's like a happy confident young lady
so I have no real worries about it no
worries but feels really good when you
have a rescue dog is when you go out of
town and they're staying with someone
who has a lot more expertise and
experience with the breed of dog than
you do yeah and you own it and there's
other dogs of her type there and there's
your impression of when they all get in
the same room all the Greyhounds they
all just stand next to each other and
like don't look at each other don't
interact theirs goes up we're great
house just like sit and stare like stand
greyhounds be like they all stand like
super close to each other just all
standing it's up a grey house that's it
yeah so we're gonna take her and then
Marlon my brother is gonna come to the
house and watch the littles oh we got
clean the house yeah we'll clean this oh
I have a lot of laundry to do will you
do my laundry for me please you asking
me to do your laundry yes please I don't
want to do it my all stop working I
think it's kind of a weird thing to ask
your friend to do please friend I don't
know friend please I think it's kind of
weird why you know what else is
happening this Friday what the release
of my fanny pack and if you want you can
go to the Scrabble website to get the
coolest fanny pack around just do that
yeah I just say way to my own little
sponsor did you have it on the podcast
like last time I don't remember I don't
recall yes I did you've been wearing it
I wear it I wear it every day I can't
get this thing off it's my favorite bag
of it honestly it's turned out to be so
wonderful because I wanted to make a
cool bag but now I selfishly just like
love this bag more than any of my other
fanny packs are we really gonna sit back
to back the entire podcast no let's go
back okay it felt weird oh my god is
that what you look like you're beautiful
what like we're gonna see something else
so hold on over on the phone what would
you say baby you're not on the phone
stop it
I've been doing this thing on when I'm
screaming anytime with like Caleb or
Jason I'll just be like oh I'll
compliment them like you know Caleb I
really like what you did with that a
piece of graphic design I think sorry I
was talking to chat would you say his
name you're beautiful Oh like a friend
way cool hat explain it and it's me dude
okay it's the brand I'm sure you've
never heard of cool they make cool stuff
but you've never heard of them I've
never heard of them I hear they're
coming out with some new stuff in the
next couple of weeks
yeah maybe who knows that wasn't us so
we had this I know we didn't have an
idea someone else had an idea we don't
get ideas anymore I don't get ideas
anymore I get ideas sometimes most of
the time I'm just looking on onto the
digital notepads of other people's ideas
aka Twitter sometimes my brain makes
thoughts and sometimes it just doesn't
so that's about it that's gonna be
someone's senior quote yeah makes
thoughts and other times it doesn't yeah
I think that's pretty good yeah anyway
so some idea came from somewhere of some
brain that we get a list of celebrities
and we guess their zodiac signs so we're
gonna do that that's it oh we tried to
call first of all we didn't look up any
of these people zodiac signs so we're
gonna have to look them up live on the
podcasts obviously because it's not like
we have a a producer to throw it to that
can give us the answer no we have Donald
over there little Donald he's our
producer we hired hi Donald are you good
food there's nobody there
I thought I heard a producer [ __ ]
if you think if we had a producer but we
don't have we're left on our own devices
I feel part and low on the charts
because they don't have a producer but
we tried to come up with celebrities
that have like relatively big
personalities I'd say so that it would
be more fun to guess yeah and I'm gonna
do terrible at this
so they do terrible to fair warning and
also I feel like we're gonna offend some
somebody I'm an Aries by the way well we
didn't know that I just wanted to put
that on the table we had no idea
I put the Aries in Aries Wow okay you
know all of it the whole word I put into
it well okay so let's start with why
don't you read the short little summary
of the signs because I'm extremely
familiar what I'm sure a lot of you guys
are too I'm extremely familiar with the
signs that I interact with on a regular
basis right but some of the other ones
I'm a little less familiar unless I had
a friend or we areand we can use it as a
cheat sheet - we can look back on it as
we're guessing - yeah I'll read them
right now Aries enthusiastic outgoing
self-centered wonderful amazing
incredible the best Julian that's not
what it says okay self-centered
energetic pioneering assertive Tory wait
wait wait wait what's that
slow down what what is these are these
all the the goods the good and the bad
let me see I'm so confused what's going
on on your iPad why if your clients
going through that what is that
Julian baby baby oh yeah I cut off half
of it Julian got an iPad and it's like
everywhere way no no it's it's this okay
wait hold on okay so it's like a short
little summary
of of each son okay with like ten no and
these seem really nice
yeah it's because to say that your
enthusiastic outgoing self-centered
energetic pioneering and assertive is
sort of glazing over the rest of it but
yeah this is gonna be a positive podcast
it's the pop positive and we're not
gonna talk about people's negative
traits we're just not we're gonna make
everything positive because it's the
positive cast Taurus stable have
negative traits steadfast patient
practical stubborn stubborn jealous
artsy so they're not all positive this
is not the partisan Gemini communicative
inquisitive adaptable versatile okay
cancer sensitive
I knew that cancer cry a lot right
nurturing receptive home and family
oriented emotional yeah they're
sensitive an emotional there I'm
surprising her masada cancer Leo
generous showy dramatic
creative a leader egotistical fun-loving
that one I can see Virgo analytical
discriminating critical detail oriented
service minded useful have you don't
like a youthful you you put that you and
useful thank you
Libra diplomatic other oriented like
other people oriented whatever
peace-loving refined flirty indecisive
flirty yeah my nephews a Libra you see
every time I talk to him on the phone
he's just got the biggest smile that boy
that boy Ladykiller
alright Scorpio magnetic powerful
intense persevering passionate extreme
magnetic powerful magnetic powerful
intense persevering passionate extreme
okay
Sagittarius idealistic optimistic
scattered honest exaggerative said a
word Restless
Capricorn ambitious responsible
economical efficient disciplined
insensitive damn they're not sensitive
at all they're insensitive like incense
okay
Aquarius impersonal detached original
humanitarian independent rebellious
Pisces sympathetic sentimental caring
responsive psychic spiritual escapist
how is one of their psychic that's crap
shall we begin I'm ready to begin
Guy Fieri oh okay um so we know that he
loves food that's about it I feel like
he needs to be one of the bigger
personalities he's definitely a big
personality we are moving this down here
because I need the cheat sheet on that
she cheats right here okay thank you
well he could be a Scorpio because he's
magnetic and powerful also intense and
passionate and extreme Scorpio does say
extreme I would say leo but I don't see
him as much of a leader Wow
what I'm trying to be honest here I'm
not sparing feelings Wow
I would follow guy fury on Twitter
yeah but following someone on Twitter
doesn't mean they're leading you he owns
many restaurants he's a leader he's a
successful businessman I just don't know
if his personality is Lee is a leader
but maybe he's a Leo what what do you
think he's like I don't think he's an
earth sign he's not an earth sign but
how do I tell what's earth and what's
not um we'll probably figure it out I
don't know all of them well I think Leo
is a good guess but I think he's a
little more all over the place ooh which
one is all over the place a turd
Sagittarius oh he could be a sadder
ative restless Oh
I don't know watching dudes be like a
tourist
oh all right who's gonna look it up what
you look at
I'm gonna guess Scorpio and you're gonna
guess Sagittarius yep
all right place your guesses in your
brain or wherever you're Lister but I'll
look up their birth dates is that cool
and you can tell me I don't have the
dates here yes you do I do
January 22nd is he a Capricorn
he's an Aquarius he's an Aquarius
Aquarius impersonal detached original
humanitarian independent rebellious Wow
we were both up Aquarian men are just
like they drive me crazy they just like
to watch everyone else like have a
meltdown and think it's [ __ ]
hysterical you know I'm saying I don't I
don't recall no thank you
no think they think it's funny Will's an
Aquarius it's like when shit's hittin
the fan and we're all like yelling and
screaming and he's just sitting there
dying laughing he loves watching other
people freak out that's like an Aquarius
in a nutshell
but only a guy Aquarius yeah girl
acquaintance are a little different but
I feel like in my experience guy
Aquarian it's like if the world is
burning around them this they kick back
and [ __ ] dying laughing it's a good
trick I love watching the chaos that's a
good trait to have it and I'm like hello
you because I'm prone to freaking the
[ __ ] out that is what I don't need
laughing it is so funny because it's
literally like it's the opposite
reaction that you have to situations
like that you are the most dramatic when
things are no listen when things are in
your mind going wrong there is no making
you happy about it yeah you've made the
decision that is all panel so I can see
why that type of personality would get
to you yeah I'm like the world is
brewing
so weird is his birthday really this
22nd of January that's what it says I
never would have guessed him to be that
I mean maybe it's just all on camera and
then when he's off camera he's just very
different did you know that his my god
my brain his given name is guy Ramsay
ferry okay not Fieri
yeah I'm just that was a pseudonym guy
Ramsay ferry no one's name is Fieri
actually that's not true that sounds
good
wait so I always thought like people
were like oh you're pronouncing it wrong
it's be Eddie right that's how he likes
to pronounce the idea but that's his but
your last name is ferry but that's it's
his stage name or something like a
stripper or an actor then why do you
make me say it Fiat II I don't make you
do anything no not you him Oh why are
you looking at me when you're talking to
him talk to the camera that's him come
on address him address guy why do you
make me safe Yeti if your lesson is
buried we'll find out on the next
episode of this whatever the [ __ ] this
is next person dr. Phil okay he is
what's the word for thinking you're
really smart
or it may be really smart inquisitive
oh sorry inquisitive I think he's a
giving caring person oh you're hogging
the whole cheatsheet and I can't help
you no no no that's not fair no look at
this look how cool this is what you just
scrolled that's all ooh okay a cancer is
sensitive nurturing nurturing receptive
home and family-oriented and fun-loving
he's not he could be a Virgo a little
cerebral he could be a Virgo it could be
a Virgo but I don't know I don't think
so um why are you sorry Karen you see
Scorpio is powerful
and passionate is he passionate well I
know I just saw a Libra is flirty and he
is very flirty he's flirting with the
crowd
Liz yeah no he's not what about a Taurus
he could be a Taurus a practical
stubborn jealous and I see he's not
artsy I saw that he's not artsy unless
he's the artsy what would a Gemini
communicative inquisitive adapt
inquisitive inquisitive that's the word
I was looking for you think doctor
well he's duality right what's the
duality the duality is he'll be calm and
sitting there and then he'll just come
out with some really like loud and
intense [ __ ] out of his mouth like you
know he'll be like listening and be like
yeah I understand okay explain to me the
situation and then I'd be like you're
making her feel bad you know it's like
very it's a change of tone he can change
cuz it's like he needs people in their
play he needs to be the good cop and the
bad cop because it's not I think he's a
Capricorn know we were talking about
Gemini sorry go ahead
ambitious responsible economical
efficient disciplined in sense it
insensitive but they're not it's like my
mom in Rome are both capricoins they're
not insensitive you know they're just
like they just don't put up with your
[ __ ]
whatever all right I'm gonna go with
Gemini I'm gonna go with Capricorn okay
I'm gonna look it up I'll win we should
keep scoring by the way okay neither of
us are winning Jay is Jenna and then Jay
over here is Julian September 1st he's a
Virgo 1950 he's a [ __ ] virgin he's a
Virgo dammit I should have gone with
Virgo
okay that would be my second guess
though because that would be my sin
virgos are like that with the lake he's
a Virgo dude ah how did we [ __ ] we had
literally said we said it at the
beginning you're like he's probably a
Virgo he's done yeah so can I
no okay all right he's a Virgo Wow of
course he's useful lovers hello we're
useful it's not Peugeot season anymore
it's today's the end of Virgo season
it's last welcome libras hmm oh God
guys are gonna love this next person or
you're gonna have no ideas are and and
then if you didn't know who they were
now you need to fall down a very weird
hole of the internet and we're talking
about the CEO of bang energy what is
that guy like what sign is he but also
like what is that guy there is a girl
that made a really good comprehensive I
watch her name is Casey ion so CA se y
AO and s oh and I watched that video
because it was recommended to me and it
was spectacular but it opened my eyes to
the world of this this guy but if you
know what we're talking about you can
guess on this one if you don't you can
just skip it but we this guy is out
there he's an eccentric eccentric is
hearing it lately
let me play a clip of him this is from
her video it's gonna make you feel
watching all these videos I can't even
be surprised that this is an actual
poster in their board room there's like
clips of him I should just go to his
Instagram I forget well I want to start
guessing okay guess I think he's
probably a Leo I'm sorry he got this the
Gorm's
egotistical showy dramatic this is that
guy's all those things he's also
delusional but that's not on any of
these signs what the hell dude
women perform high repetitions with
light weight however a new study
suggests that women should train did he
even loved my researchers had seen us
train for nine weeks he's like four
inches from not easily he's talking in
the mic like this he ingested the log
he's a Leo he has to be a Leo not not
and honestly no shade to other Leo's
because this is like the most intense
crazy leo that you can find
I think he's Leo what else could he be
um he's not could be a Scorpio magnetic
powerful intense persevering passionate
and extremely could be a Scorpio
powerful intense passionate extreme
egotistical fun-loving see we know a lot
of Leo's and they're not like that
they're wonderful little but not in a
bad way there's there could be a
negative part of it you know like Lexi
and Jason are both Leo's and they're
both very confident wonderful fun-loving
people but they're not you go tests I
mean they're not yeah egotistical has a
connotation yeah
look it up my guess is Scorpio alright
I'm gonna go with Leo I'm gonna say he's
one of the more extreme Leos I got a I
don't know his name just google his name
first CEO of bang energy let me see his
name is Jack a walk a we're gonna be
able to find out Jack Jack a walk
birthday birthday all right you ready
fifteen what is he he is a Gemini
what do allottee okay that's that makes
sense I guess all right we're all
communicative inquisitive adaptable
adaptable and versatile you know I mean
he was sitting on Instagram just talking
about all these research studies he is
very quick but also like I in the videos
we watched of him from falling down that
rabbit hole that girl's videos like you
see videos of him being so loud and
eccentric and crazy and then there's
other videos I'm just kind of not being
like that yeah and I think when you have
that insane personnel you have to have
the duality okay who's next
what does he Gemini
Jim Julia Roberts what do you think
Julia Roberts is Evelyn areas you think
Julia Roberts is an Aries yeah I know
nothing about her I don't know think
about her ears all right I'm gonna use
cancer okay come on Julia please pull
through for me please pull through
please pull through be an Aries October
28th that's a Scorpio magnetic powerful
intense persevering passionate extreme
I'll take that okay
yeah that's an air sign that means well
we came up with that one we we honestly
underestimated the fact that we don't
know anything about her is the person
honestly that's true
absolutely nothing hmm so she's magnetic
powerful intense persevering passionate
extreme sort of like the extreme comfort
you get from wearing me and on your
bottom top go to me undies comm slash
and join me right now to get 15% of your
first pair of manatees and to feel the
wonderful softness and extreme comfort
of me undies they launched their feel
free collection
it was size tested on every body type
real bodies not mannequin bodies real
sizing for real women still made with
their soft soft soft soft fabric that
you will love once you try for the first
time the collection comes with five new
undies silhouettes including a bralette
for the least bra bra you'll ever want
to wear trust me I've seen her wear the
field yeah it's made softer with a
signature softer than clouds micro model
fabric like I said there are fun new
prints that drop every single month
there's actually a lot of friends at
this point they have so many prints to
choose from and then they also have like
basic really nice colors that I've been
enjoying does that mean I'm getting old
that I like basic colored underwear no
yeah it does
anyway I have a drawer in the other room
filled with me and he's underwear and I
love it and it's my favorite underwear
ever and it's Jenna's favorite underwear
ever and right now it could be your
favorite underwear ever if you go to
meet undies comm slash Jenna Julianne
get 15% off free shipping and you're
gonna be satisfied they guarantee it
they guarantee it it's their guarantee
also I guarantee you're gonna enjoy
yourself if you build a website with
Squarespace if you're wondering what it
takes to build a website the answer is
not a lot because Squarespace does a lot
of the hard work for you and they make
it a nice easy breezy not beautiful
process
I almost infringed on a different brand
there he live ah don't tap my mic mmm
there's quick setup there's a thousands
of design templates and it's the best
best price for building a website
guaranteed with an SEO wizard that helps
market your website SEO is huge for your
website for those who don't know is
search engine optimization and they help
you optimize your website not only in
the visual sense and how it looks but
also how it performs when people are
searching for you and your potential
services it's a really important part of
having a website at a small business so
if you are a small business owner or
even if it's just for your hobby you
want people to look at your website that
is a cool feature that they have they
also have live webinars that you can
watch and 24 hours a day 7 days a week
customer service also I don't know if I
mentioned already but Keanu Reeves uses
Squarespace so that's the end of the
sales pitch you should do it because he
does it all so idris elba he's great go
to squarespace.com slash Jenna Julianne
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain and when you build
your website tweet it at us I love
looking at yells web sites you a bunch
of you guys have done
and it's really cool to check out what
you've done so check it out with
Squarespace or click the link down below
and the underpants no immuno saying
underpants okay so she is uh what was
she
scorpy else Corp scorp there's lots a
skort
Gordon Ramsay what's fire something like
is he an Aries he might be an Aries I
don't think he's an Aries listen I think
some of the best chefs in the world are
Aries I think that's how it works
I think you're biased I think you're
biased virgos dr. Phil's America he is
[Music]
you know how they say virgos are
judgmental mm I could see why he's a
Virgo hmm because he can be pretty judgy
sometimes mmm
are you just saying on offense is it
sitting on the fence noise yeah okay do
you have it sit on the fence
mm-hmm you go face down with the post in
your mouth face down ass up that's sweet
dr. Phil likes to talk to people on show
he puts his face down his ass up on a
show and talks to people I wish you
didn't say that but it's too late now I
really wish that wasn't said now I can
only think about his face down in his
ass up and inevitably someone's gonna
draw that I'm sorry back to Gordon Randy
I feel like he could be Leo he's
possibly Leo very showy so likeable
though like he's he's likeable the the
big personality the but like really
sweet really carrying really nice really
thoughtful but like you could call him
egotistical but it's not necessarily a
negative thing I think he's a Leo or a
Scorpio I think he has he has
characteristics of both but I like you
said I don't think he's an Aries um just
because he's like loud and
energetic yeah I think he's more
calculated and more like he's showy like
when it's you know when the camera goes
on and he's hosting a show or he's
filming whatever it's like he commands
the room what if he's a tourist though
stable stubborn artsy he's not ours
I don't think like Tauruses usually
aren't that like in your face though you
know yeah he's got a big personality and
yeah I think he's uh
I'm gonna guess leo I would guess Leo
too let's look it up Gordon
what are you why do I feel like his
birthdays in like June or something
though June 19th he's a Gemini what the
[ __ ] dude why are we so bad at this wait
wait wait what I think I've looked up
something wrong this is that he died
November 5th he's alive 1993 okay I
looked up the wrong person Gordon Ramsay
American television stage and voice
actor who was based in New York City why
is that the first thing that comes up
when I look up Gordon Ramsay that's the
first Gordon Ramsay it comes up yeah
okay here here's the right Gordon Ramsay
sorry
November 8th November 8th he's a Scorpio
Wow that makes sense okay wrong one
magnetic powerful intense persevering
passionate we should have gone with
Scorpio it's not like we weren't off we
were close very close
all right Scorpio scorp Julian not Mark
Cuban hmm
mm is there a sign for fake gluten-free
oh okay what's a sign that would lie
about being gluten-free then constantly
and then eat bread impersonal aquarius
oops I think he's a Leo or or he could
be I don't know what if he's an Aries
I'm gonna go with Aries yeah you know
you're not wrong you might be in area so
the wait the way okay so on shark tank
for example sometimes this is what I'll
do right the pitch is beginning and
he'll just be sitting there and you can
tell he's like his mind is elsewhere
he'll just be like oh you know energy
bars is a market I don't get to I'm out
and then he'll just like zone out and
then the last that can be like what
million don't do that deal right now
right now right now he does it you guys
like how are you
Aries energy Aries Aries energy come on
right give us this one give us this one
give him the same birthday as me I want
him to have the same birthday as me July
31st David he's a Leo usually Oh hazily
oh sure you're making that a mess oh my
god you're writing so big all over
everything I can't see who is the next
person Keanu Reeves I don't know I do
know cancer I say he's a cancer because
he's sensitive mm-hmm
I don't think he's home and
family-oriented
what about like his parents or siblings
or that kind of thing I don't think it
necessarily means that you have to have
like a wife and kids
I think anyone who meets him likes him
and he's like just watching him interact
with people makes me feel like he he
just cares about people a lot mm-hmm
humanitarian how is someone
impersonal and a humanitarian he could
be a tourist
he reminds me of tourists energy stable
steadfast patient practical stubborn
yeah Taurus it could really be you
Taurus
I haven't made my guess yet we better
guess boy my guess is cancer our
tourists but pick one pick one if you
pick cancer all pectoris alright my
first guest was cancer so I'm gonna stay
open tortoise counter reads birthday
September 2nd he's a Virgo he's a Virgo
Beach I can see that I can totally see
that like yeah nice nice my guy that's
awesome
virgos are the best damn graduate being
the same size that's Keanu I guess that
makes sense like the way he keeps to
himself like sometimes you know we
really just be known on a park bench
yeah reason whatsoever someone's like
are you okay I'm like yeah I'm solitary
I just honestly wasn't even here they
thrive in solitary we do Nicolas Cage
let's [ __ ] go oh let's [ __ ] go
alright I'm gonna guess something like
off-center like what if he was like a
Libra flirty you know flirt with me Nick
because I think we like to think of him
as the characters that he is yeah
eccentric but I think he is a little
eccentric like as a person but I'm not
sure I don't I guess I don't know
anything about him as a person yeah I
know nothing about him as a person so
we're really judging he's been married
four times or so we were judging on how
he acts yeah even though he's acting you
can kind of look through that and see
how a person is yeah
maybe a Scorpio I guess everyone's a
scorpio huh who what sign do you trust
the least
Aquarians I think I'm gonna pick her
querías I would say the same okay go
I think yeah I think Aquarius I'm gonna
guess Libra you guess Aquarius Nicolas
Cage birthday it's gotta be January you
think so because it's January 7th
it's Caprica he's a Capricorn see look
at that like something just that I did
not expect at all he's the Capricorn
he's a Capricorn nice acting my dude
damn close to Aquarius though nice
acting my dude I don't know if you know
this but nice acting you should try it
sometime
by the way I've seen a lot of you last
we've taken we've kind of paused our
quest to finish every Nicholas Cage
movie yeah aren't you just picks some of
your favorites out there we don't have
to do it yeah yeah we'll pick some other
favorites where are you going Mariah K
Julian cancer Julian no rewind how do
you spell Mariah Carey okay K Rui yeah
kar you CA Rui Julian where I okay wait
can I call him Ricky no she spells her
name with a c' c' just doesn't have the
same ring you've never seen the word
more i have it's always just mariah it's
just like by itself what do you think
she is this is some nice uh glazing over
him the fact that you just called her
Mariah Kay okay can we get over it move
on okay um something funny she's funny
she's funny mm-hmm that's not a that's
not a sign mm-hmm no what about a
Sagittarius idealistic opera is this
scattered honest exaggerative and
restless what is this one exaggerated no
is this game gonna be the first to one
point because neither of us have a
[ __ ] point yeah it's like a soccer
game
nice what if she's a Gemini dude I could
see her beat I could see you being in
Gemini Terry yeah I really like Gemini's
here's what Ares self-centered energetic
assertive Ares she's an Aries
no watch her be in Aries though hmm what
if there was a year that everyone born
in that year was one side that's wild
that's like the the Chinese zodiac cray
I don't know I never never seen it never
been I think Mariah Carey's um I don't
know well think about it this way right
I think she's it I guess she's gonna
I'll guess Gemini no but everyone's got
duality to them right Gemini is like is
a misleading sign because it's like you
say oh yeah they have duality like I've
been saying this whole time but the
reality is a lot of people have
different personalities you just like
act differently sometimes I'm guessing
Gemini because it says adaptable and boy
did you see that New Year's Eve
performance she adapted no she did she -
she threw her dancers under the bus
hell yeah and complain the whole time
exact that's not adapting I'm ready to
look up that and say that's just no my
girl adapted and let me let me just look
at Mariah Kay's birthday March 27 let's
go is she oh one point for me
Oh doo-doo-doo Oh
dude she's our Ares Queen Wow that is
[ __ ] hype Wow
Aries women I feel like are a little
less intense incorrect like Shannon
Koresh Oh sometimes someone will say
something to her she'll be the [ __ ] up
out of nowhere and they'll be like why
are you
I don't know yeah but Shan doesn't make
me crazy sometimes you make me crazy I
think it's a boy and a girl thing I
don't think that's an Aries thing my mom
is one of the most intense people I know
she's an early Aries March 24th yeah
yeah yeah she intends to hoot Mariah my
[ __ ] sorry my queen I don't know like
the positive way okay who's next
are you excited about that yeah I mean
it's that's that's kind of how you pick
someone now mmm Gary Busey mm-hmm
no we're not using him we don't know
anything about them why don't we do what
do share share what's not there
yeah share from stuck on you sure
Scorpio magnetic powerful intense
persevering passionate in extreme she's
magnetic and powerful you look at her
that's power she is power he's power he
look up power in the dictionary there's
a picture of sharing his power she is
beauty she is grace Scorpio mmm-hmm I'm
gonna get Gemini again okay cuz I'm
running out of like ability to have any
confidence I'm running out of ability
just period end of sentence May 20th
what is she may 20th tour tourists the
last the last day on the Taurus that's
that's like the shifty one that's Taurus
is a stable steadfast patient practical
stubborn jealous artsy I personally find
some tourists just unpredictable and
like hard to read my brother's a Taurus
some damsels say something and I'm just
like where in the world did that come
from
my dad's a Taurus so cher hanging out
with her would be a trip mmm if she
would just come out of nowhere that's
probably even keeled energy yeah which
are like an honorary Virgo
No yeah I don't have even killed energy
that's true you it's like the world is
[ __ ] ending chill chill chill chill
chill chill [ __ ] everybody chill I'm the
direction opposite I'm always at the top
and then occasionally I'll go down
[Laughter]
that's the way to live life baby
you live life don't let life live you
excuse you put my Apple pencil what else
we saw who we get stops
Aquarius Virgo Gemini Scorpio I can't
read those anymore cause you started
scribbling but Kiana's a Virgo we know
that vocalist cage is see now you forgot
oh Capricorn
he's a Capricorn Gordon Ramsay you
forgot because you scribbled over
everything yeah well whatever let's do
one more okay you pick yeah it's for
it's it's zodiac time I feel like his
birthday is in June I feel like he's a
cancer I don't know why I feel like this
birthday is in June do you think he's a
cancer I don't know why I think that
what is Will Smith is this like it yes
it is essential question what is he to
his core
what is he I don't know can I guess also
that there's a person on that list named
REE Drummond and I think she's a cancer
as well that's the one that she's very
sensitive okay well there was nothing
read they're both dancers both of them
I'm gonna go with Aries for Will Smith I
don't think that's a bad guess yeah I
think he might be an Aries yeah I see I
see why no all right I'll look it up
[Music]
just his behavior in the last however
long when he's done YouTube stuff
makes me feel like he's an Aries
September 25th he's after virgo libra
mm-hmm yep he's a Libra we was wrong
diplomatic other oriented flirty
indecisive refined okay okay I can
understand all right so I can see that
Will Smith Libra REE Drummond I feel
like the answer the Pioneer Woman she's
home and family oriented emotional
nurturing sensitive receptive I think
you're right I think she's a cancer she
if she's not I'm gonna be devastated I'm
sure be a Virgo or something REE
Drummond birthday like that it has to be
a cancer oh my god January 6 1969 how's
it Capricorn
that's the Dark Horse today Capricorn is
absolutely the Dark Horse we keep in
capricorns yeah they keep putting a
Capricorn in our ass Wow poppin
capricorns in the house see capricorns
are very versatile I like them they I
get along they are corns better than
anyone else in the zodiac I feel like I
they could be anyone oh [ __ ] you know
like you look at someone you're like
that person is very clear cancer traits
or very clear Aries trades or Virgo
traits or Taurus traits or Scorpio Tracy
Leo traits nope Capricorn it's because
they're the all one of the oldest right
in the zodiac
oh it says here I have no idea yeah
third oldest these go in order
so Aries the angel baby infant newborn
children first Capricorn is all the way
down here close to the very end you're
right in the middle perfectly even yeah
exactly I couldn't choose a side yeah
capricorns the third oldest Pisces the
oldest Aquarius is a second all this
this is why I don't trust
Aquarians they [ __ ] think they know
everything look at them all the way down
I'm in the middle experiencing genuine
pain in anguish and they're like ha ha
ha ha and I'd be like yeah
[Laughter]
that's the only time you ever turn off
I'm just excited to talk to filled with
Virgo I'm excited that mariah is an
Aries she's my new queen have you heard
of her she's an Aries no how do you
spell your last name okay okay are you
okay for Queen okay you
I hate w/e and eh oh well thank you it's
a really fun game that I wasn't really
like guessing people shout out to guy
fieri dr. Phil guy from bang Julia
Roberts Gordon Ramsay Mark Cuban Keanu
Reeves Nicolas Cage Will Smith
share because they sent in their signs
oh yeah thank you guys for sending in to
our producer Thank You Donald our
producer in the corner I hope you guys
do the podcast this week this was
actually a lot of fun oh yeah we'll be
back next week pretty sure we're gonna
switch con it might be I think if I'm
not mistaken it might be like a shorter
podcasting but I'm not sure we'll see
but every not the podcast before we go
yeah the what my question is is if we
have it like marked off on the calendar
but even if we do I think we should
still do like a short one we'll see well
we'll do what we can but um I'm not
gonna see you until these bags go for
sale so Friday if you want to get one of
these myself Friday 8:00 a.m. Pacific
I'll tweet about it so don't worry thank
you guys for listening the podcast hope
you have a wonderful day and week and
we'll catch you on the next one
Oh
[Music]